[Music]
I'm Priscilla and I'm one of the talkers
for talk of the day I first got started
doing it because it was just a way for
me to find an escape from the typical
routine and MIT really let me with my
partner Jessica to kind of artistically
experiment and challenge ourselves in
ways that really ended up surprising us
I think it's nice because we're all very
busy and so like setting us apart an
hour every week to do something artistic
and not think about work is really nice
Sarah I'm here and I've been talking
since freshman year so it's been awesome
what is it was like
yeah I'm Charlene I'm a senior and I
study computer science here and I think
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna be like yeah
words are really powerful and so being
able to kind of like convey the meaning
of the word like the way that you were
right it is like kind of interesting to
me
[Applause]
[Music]
there is a good creative process that I
have to engage but like it's a totally
different way that I approach in a math
problem versus the way that I approach
like a blank
[Music]
it puts a smile on people's faces
it's spread the positive message to
people who pass by it also hopefully
like encourages other people to pursue
some form of art and to be more true to
the matter
[Applause]
[Music]
you